este jueves Mario Vargas llosa se
convertirá en inmortal así se les conoce
a los miembros de la academia francesa
de la lengua Una institución creada en
el siglo 17 para preservar el idioma
francés lo hará en una ceremonia marcada
por la tradición vestido de levita de
paño negro con las solapas abordadas de
hilos verdes y dorados y con una espada
que fue diseñada a su gusto para esta
ocasión durante esta ceremonia dará un
discurso en homenaje a su predecesor el
filósofo Michelle esta ceremonia estará
acompañado por sus hijos por su segunda
exesposa y también con un invitado que
causó revuelo el rey emérito Juan Carlos
primero de España revuelo ha causado
también el anuncio de su entrada a esta
academia eso fue en noviembre de 2021
porque se hicieron varias excepciones a
la regla Por una parte el hecho de que
tuviera 85 años 10 más de lo que aplica
en el reglamento y sobre todo porque es
el primer autor que no ha escrito un
solo libro en francés y que hace ya su
instalación en esta academia francesa
todo esto a pesar de que su obra sí toda
está traducida ya al idioma de molleja
pero sobre todo lo que más polémica
causó eso sobre todo entre los
intelectuales franceses que no
consideraban a Vargas llosa a pesar de
ser Premio Nobel pues digno de
pertenecer a esta institución sobre todo
por sus posturas de apoyo a la
ultraderecha en América Latina